la droite républicaine virtel trop à
droite du rpr à l air la question s'est
posée la première fois c'était en 1986
après l'élection des premiers députés
frontistes et à leurs ventes en retard
trente cinq députés d'extrême droite
9,65 % des voix et un électorat que la
droite veut reconquérir quelques mois
plus tard le ministre de l'intérieur
charles pasqua s'illustre avec la sphère
des charters nous avons pris la décision
d'expulser un certain nombre de maliens
inquiet de la situation
le rpr s'approprie la thématique phare
du fn l'immigration
alors peut-on dans notre pays parler de
l'immigration en termes vrai où est on
condamné à la langue de bois
pas de langue de bois bien au contraire
mais un discours en 1991 sur les
immigrés polygame qui profitent des
aides sociales
et cette phrase choc si vous ajoutez à
cela le bruit et l'odeur est bien le
travailleur français sur le palier
deviens fou en 1993 le rpr obtient la
majorité à l'assemblée alors que le fn
n'a plus qu'un siège en 95 jacques
chirac est élu président de la
république l'immigration et la sécurité
prennent de l'importance au sein de la
majorité
deux lois sur l'immigration sont
débattus l'opposition résume cette ligne
en trois mots la lepénisation des
esprits
en 2007 nicolas sarkozy succède à
jacques chirac et compte aller plus loin
que son prédécesseur ou un ministère de
l'immigration nationale et de l'identité
nationale
un ministère et un grand débat sur
l'identité nationale qui vient
rapidement à un grand débat sur l'islam
l'opposition dénonce une dérive et au
sein même de l'ump
des ténors se fâche au nom de quoi les
stigmatiserait tombe et leur refuserait
t'on le droit d'exercer la religion j'ai
pas tout à fait la certitude que le
débat soit conçu dans cet esprit mars ça
qui me préoccupe la fracture entre
membres du parti aura contribué à la
défaite de nicolas sarkozy à la
présidentielle de 2012 aux législatives
pour se relever
l'ump hésite à s'allier au front
national
on n'a pas à se pincer le nez lorsqu'on
parle du front national qui est
effectivement un parti républicain sinon
il serait interdit
ça n'a pas de sens pour l'instant et ça
n'a pas de sens d'évoquer ce sujet à ce
moment en 2017 après son élimination au
premier tour de la présidentielle
françois fillon annonce qu'il votera
contre marine le pen dont pour emmanuel
macron par dépit ces parties de ce jeudi
je cache pas qui aurait souhaité qu'ils
sont battus pour ça que la position du
bureau politique soit pu naître les
républicains d'aujourd'hui sont
tiraillés entre lepénisme et macro nisme
avec un nouveau président
le parti espère clarifier sa ligne
[Musique]